this is Zana am a cheese tree kangaroo  she's adorable isn't she but don't let  her adorableness to see you  this rare kangaroo is extremely  threatened with curved claws and stocky  muscular limbs she's at harm in the  trees however her padded paws allow her  to fall from up to 60 feet without  injury  this marsupial is so rare it can only be  found in the mountainous rainforests of  northeastern Papua New Guinea  it's a solitary creature that spends  most of its time alone except for when  there's a baby to care for tree kangaroo  Joey's spend 18 months with their  mothers before setting out on their own  oil drilling and logging are destroying  the match's habitat and it's thick  beautiful fur has made it an attractive  target for native hunters captive  breeding and local education efforts are  making headway but its future is  uncertain this is the match's tree  kangaroo